the chair of the health and social care
committee jeremy hunt former health
secretary of course so let's just get
that out of the way to start with mr
hunt good morning to you been a problem
for 15 years
says the nurse which i mean to what
extent do you accept some responsibility
for that given that you were previously
health secretary
well of course i have to accept some
responsibility but i did set up six new
medical schools
and increase the number of doctors we
train by 25
the problem is because it takes seven
years to train a doctor we won't get any
of those additional doctors through
until 2024
and this is really the point we're
making in our report that we need to
have a system that's much more robust
that doesn't depend on individual health
secretaries or chancellors taking
decisions but gives the nhs confidence
that whoever the government is whoever
the health sector is we will always be
training enough doctors and nurses for
the future and at the moment
we think we're about 12 000 hospital
doctors short about 50 000 nurses short
and that is creating massive pressure on
frontline staff and we are very
frustrated in the committee that despite
having talked about this now for a
couple of years we still don't have a
proper nhs workforce plan in place nor
do we have one in place for the social
care sector as you were just talking
about with professor mortensen
yeah um how close do you think the
government is going to be to recruiting
the 6 000 gps that it promised in the
manifesto
well it's it's not easy recruiting extra
gps but since they made that promise in
the 2019 manifesto which i obviously
stood on as a conservative as well
we've gone down by about 700 gps a year
ago we said we needed 2 000 more
midwives we've gone down 500 midwives
and i think people in the nhs know
there's no silver bullet they know it
takes three years to train a midwife
seven years to train a doctor 10 years
to train a gp
there's no easy solutions but what they
want is a really solid plan in place so
that you know young people entering the
profession today can at least have some
hope that the pressure isn't always
going to be like it is today
you've been warning i know about the
crisis the workforce crisis for a long
time we've spoken about it often on this
program
you are backing rishi sunak who didn't
i think i'm right in saying you'll
correct me um who didn't vote for your
amendment in parliament to produce a
workforce plan and he's not really said
that much so far about the workforce
when it comes to talking about the nhs
either in hustings or on tv debates does
he get it
well i think i do give him credit that
of the two candidates he's the first
who's actually spoken about the nhs and
he's he's used the word emergency and i
think that's very important because
that's what it feels like on the front
line at the moment that's what it feels
like i think for some of the people who
are waiting for their nhs care um but
the reason i'm supporting is because the
reason i'm a conservative is because i
think only conservative governments take
the tough and difficult long-term
decisions that the country needs
and he was prepared to say publicly that
we can't afford unfunded tax cuts and i
thought that was very brave and i want
someone who who leads us who tells us
things that we don't always want to hear
that's what i think we should have from
a prime minister and i hope we would
have that when it comes to some
difficult decisions respecting the nhs
as well
yeah you said a crisis is referred to as
a crisis is also talked about as having
to be on a war forcing to deal with it
but to
to fight a war you need to have troops
don't you um and as you said it's taking
a while for those troops to come along
to the front line should we be looking
overseas to bring in reinforcements
yes there's lots of things we can do in
the short term in the long run of course
we should be training all the doctors
and nurses we need we're one of the
biggest healthcare systems in the world
but you know in the short term if you've
got a doctor coming from a country like
germany
or canada
why on earth do they need to go through
endless uh checks as to their medical
qualifications when we know they're
coming from a system where there's very
good medical training so we could
definitely speed things up when it comes
to relieving the pressure in the short
term you did talk he promised
certainly part of a government that
promised um
a net migration target i think under
david cameron wasn't it it didn't happen
why is rishi sunak
it appears to be doing the same thing
with his proposed asylum cap is that
what he's doing
i think it's slightly different i think
what he's saying is that um in a world
where
uh people are much much more mobile than
they've ever been we've got to recognize
that there needs to be different
structures if we're going to fulfill our
humanitarian responsibilities and we
need to pay our bit other countries need
to pay their bit and so we need to be
honest about the fact that there's a
limited amount that any one country can
do
but at the same time staying true to
britain's historical generosity to
people in difficulty coming from other
countries
how humane is it to send vulnerable
people to rwanda though
well i think the world has changed and
we used to be in a world where it was
relatively difficult to go across
continents across oceans to get to the
uk so people who came here would
claim asylum um when they got here but
now that process has become much easier
and if we don't find a different way of
helping them which doesn't encourage the
people smugglers then we are just going
to nurture a really horrible industry
that treats those people really badly so
what we need i think is to have
much better safe legal routes for people
to get here but clamp down on the people
smugglers the people who are trafficking
trafficking people in small boats across
the channel
and all the evils that that involves
completely understood but we did have a
human rights barrister on the programme
just last week and he was saying that he
would be surprised if even one person
was sent to rwanda because every time
the government tries to do that they
will face a legal challenge and they
will lose in the courts
yes and that's why i think it's very
difficult to get this right but i think
the truth is that the status quo is not
sustainable and what we're in what we're
risking at the moment is
building up a massive people smuggling
industry
and that cannot be the right way to help
people who are vulnerable so what we
need is better safe legal routes to help
people in refugee camps on the border of
syria or coming out of afghanistan help
them get here safely legally
discharge our responsibilities to be a
compassionate humane country but not
nurture this this horrible people
smuggling business what about the
suggestion of floating asylum centers uh
which has been uh suggested by your
candidate is that a good idea
we're getting quite a long way away from
my health and social care committee
report yeah but you're you know you are
you know you have previously been
foreign secretary and uh
as i know from having spoken to you
previously you can turn your hand to
anything
well that's very generous of you to say
so but um i mean
the truth is we have to be radical we
have to do things differently um and we
have to be courageous and
rishi soon to me has shown that he's
willing to be courageous in particular
uh being out front to conservative party
members of whom i'm one who all
to a person want tax cuts and say that
say that's not possible at the moment we
can't afford that right now
and i think that's the kind of courage
uh that has persuaded me that he's the
right man to be prime minister but the
same courage and decisiveness is
necessary yes when it comes to asylum
policy refugee policy as well
yeah i mean if you're going to move into
the foreign secretary role again
obviously these are the sort of
questions that people will want to know
the answers to when your man wins or
doesn't he's losing at the moment isn't
he
well um i think there's all to play for
at this stage um in the previous
leadership campaign i was uh a long way
behind boris johnson but i think the
difference between this time and last
time
is that then because of brexit a lot of
conservative party members have firmly
made up their minds this time the poll
shows that a lot of people are still
making up their minds they haven't made
their final decision maybe they wanted
some of the other candidates in the race
who are not now part of the race and so
i think there's all to play for
ten thousand tory voters want boris
johnson back
yes but that may be true i haven't seen
that exact number but there are 175 000
members and you know a decision has been
taken and we do now need to move forward
and i think we've got two excellent
candidates uh both very experienced in
government uh both done their cabinet
jobs extremely well and so i think it's
a very good choice for the conservative
party membership to have and what is it
about rishi sunak and the national
health service that makes you think that
he is a better person to try to
steer us away from up to 14 million
people on the waiting list by the time
of the next general election
well his main involvement as chancellor
has been to make sure that the nhs gets
the funding that it needs and he did
that
through the extra 12 billion pounds a
year through the health and social care
levy which again was a very difficult
decision to take
but what what we're arguing in this
report and what i i hope you would
understand as prime minister is that
it's not just about money you can put 12
billion a year or 10 billion a year as
it actually will end up being into the
nhs but if you haven't got 10 billion
bids worth of extra doctors and nurses
if you haven't got the capacity in the
system
you won't get the extra operations that
you need and so that's what we're saying
needs to happen now a very thorough
workforce plan that answers a very
simple question that's on the minds of
of every doctor and nurse in the nhs how
many extra doctors and nurses are we
going to need in the next five years and
10 years and do we have a plan in place
to recruit them
just before i let you go this is not
about the health service but it's
something that you know an awful lot
about i'm sure um given
your good lady at home confucius
institutes are something that we're
hearing quite a lot about um moving on
to china of course they are something
that are based in our um
in our universities here what are they
and why are we so worried about them
well um they were set up uh with funding
from the chinese government in
universities in this country and indeed
around the world to promote chinese
culture chinese language um but
unfortunately they've also been used
to further
chinese state aims and pushing the
objectives of the chinese communist
party in a way that i think is very
inconsistent with academic freedom so i
think rishi sunak is right
to call that out this morning and say
that you know our universities need to
be welcoming to students from all over
the world including of course china but
they need to be places where academic
freedom is totally respect there's full
freedom of speech people who want to
say things that may upset the regime in
china are completely free to do so um
and kay you've said one last thing to me
i want to say one last thing to you i'm
very sorry that the last time we met i
nearly knocked you over on my bicycle
here is my very public apology for that
in front of all the sky viewers this
morning
i think you might have tried to do it on
purpose but i'll let you i'm sure you
didn't it's great to see you thank you
very much indeed for joining us this
morning mr hunt thank you